c'est ma plus grande déception tout ça
c'est que c'est c'est qu'il ya trop de
gens qui se sont pas assumés à ce mets
toi à chaud qu'aujourd'hui a personne
qui ça seulement ça ce n'est plus je
tends à part de l'opinion puis je les
comprends parce qu'on est tous
collectivement responsables de ce qu'on
était pas trop loin de là un changement
mais la chasse aux sorcières moi j'ai
même l'impression moment donné le que
j'étais à la tête d'une chasse aux
sorcières commandé puis ont poussé dans
cette direction là et j'ai résisté de
toutes mes forces parce que c'était pas
son mot mende puis qu'est ce que vous
désirez vous pouvez noter collectivement
j'ai senti qu'on avait un besoin de
brûler des gens sur le bûcher là et puis
c'était pas le rôle la commission de
faire défiler des noms déjà qu'on
voulait entendre mon rôle et l'euro la
commission il est comme ça l'ont très
bien compris et l'équipe derrière eux
ont le don le très bien compris moi je
pense c'était de mettre à jour des
stratagèmes de mettre à jour des
pratiques des ventes et t mais comme si
on n'a qu'à être lancée pour faire le
ménage quand on a une crise l'agencé
pour crever un abcès et je pense que
c'est ça notre rôle qu'on a fait on a
passé un coup de balai la maintenance
qu'elle a couché à voir tomber ce sont
donc à voir tomber mais il fallait il
fallait fallait dégager un peu le
fallait fall a jeté de l'arrière à tout
le monde pour respirer